jouir merci beaucoup la parole est à
monsieur pierre lellouche
merci monsieur présente monsieur le
premier ministre
l'union européenne a signé avec le
canada en 2014 un important accord de
libre échange qui prévoit la quasi
suppression des droits de douane
l'harmonisation de normes l'ouverture
des marchés publics cet accord contient
cependant beaucoup de dispositions de
nature politique qui relèvent de la
souveraineté de l'état d'où la décision
des ministres représentant l'ensemble
des états de l'union en mai dernier de
considérer que cet accord est un accord
mixtes c'est-à-dire un accord non
seulement soumis à la ratification du
parlement européen mais à celui des 27
parlements nationaux à l'heure actuelle
l'accord sera soumis à la ratification
du parlement européen dans quinze jours
or dès le 1er mars la commission a
décidé de le mettre en oeuvre à titre
provisoire
sans attendre la ratification par les
états nationaux
je veux vous dire solennellement au nom
de notre groupe
qu'une telle option est de notre point
de vue insupportable et je sais que
d'autres ici partagent ce point de vue
d'autant que sur beaucoup de points cet
accord et discuter sur le mode de
règlement des différends sur la quantité
d'importations massives de viande bovine
ou de viande de porc sur ses
conséquences sur l'environnement et j'en
passe notre parlement a le droit de se
prononcer sur tous ces points
ce que confirme monsieur le premier
ministre la convention de vienne sur le
droit des traités qui stipule à son
article 25
je cite qu'un que l'application d'un
traité à titre provisoire avant son
entrée en vigueur n'est possible que si
les états parties à la négociation en
sont ainsi convenus
d'où ma question qui est double
premièrement le gouvernement français
considère t-il toujours la corse et a
comme étant un accord mix deuxième
question dans l'affirmative entente il
s'opposer comme il le doit à l'entrée en
vigueur à titre provisoire de ce traité
sans la ratification du parlement
français mais étudier l'avancée canal
jean marc ayrault ministre des affaires
étrangères
et du développement international
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
député c'est vrai que ces traités de
libre-échange donnent lieu à d'intenses
débats dans les sociétés européennes en
particulier en france mais pas seulement
c'est vrai du type traiter avec les
états unis et qui a soulevé tellement
l'interrogation et qui a provoqué tant
de désaccord que on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les cas du et que si on
va à doit aller vers un traité les
changes avec les états unis
le chantier est à reprendre il est
autant plus à reprendre que les
déclarations de l'actuel président
américain sur sa conception non pas des
négociations dans le cadre de traités ou
les intérêts des parties sont préservés
si on sait bien négocier mais à travers
des deals ce qui n'est pas une bonne
méthode pour l'avenir de la
mondialisation donc la france est par
principe favorable à des traités mais
bien sûr elle ne peut les accepter que
si toutes les conditions sont réunies
pour qu'il puisse répondre à nos
intérêts et nous intéresser à la fois
nos intérêts économiques
c'est nos intérêts sociaux ces normes
environnementales c'est le principe de
précaution c'est la règlement des
contentieux non pas par des tribunaux
privé mais par des tribunaux avec des
magistrats indépendants et c'est
justement ce qui a été négocié avec le
canada et je l'aï souvent à nos
partenaires américains qui ne comprenait
pas pourquoi nous ne savions pas à leurs
demandes
parce que nous partions sur de nouvelles
mauvaises bases et qu'avec la
négociation du ceta nous étions dans un
cadre totalement différent et que
évidemment la france est favorable à la
conclusion à laquelle nous sommes
arrivés mais en même temps vous l'avais
dit il ya des dispositions qui relèvent
de la décision nationale
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
demandé bien que ça soit l'europe qui
négocie au nom de tous que la
ratification se fasse à la fois au
niveau du parlement européen mais au
niveau du parlement national
c'est ce qui se fera et donc le traité
ne sera effectif que quand cette
ratification seront intervenus
s'il ya quelques mesures qui peuvent
être mises en oeuvre par anticipation
elles ne sont qu'à la marge c'est la
raison pour laquelle la france n'y est
pas opposée